>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Lee Ann Potter: So good morning.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
How many of you have
been here before?
All right.
How many of you have
never been here before?
So good mix.
I'm Lee Ann Potter.
I direct educational
outreach here at the library.
>> Mary Lou Reker: And I'm Mary Lou
Reker, and I oversee the doctoral
and post-doctoral fellowships
here at the library
at the John W. Kluge Center.
>> Lee Ann Potter: And we are
really tickled that you're here.
A couple of months ago when Mary Lou
approached me and said we're going
to have a small group of World
War One scholars at the library
in the spring doing research
on political cartoons
to see what we can glean about World
War One simply through the cartoons
that were published in newspapers
around the world, I was intrigued
because I remember when
I was in the classroom,
my students got a real kick out of
political cartoons, and she said,
"We need your help identifying some
groups of students who could come
and work with the scholars."
And I got to tell you when she
said World War one scholars,
the picture in my head was not
quite what you're getting today.
And without being completely
cruel to World War One scholars,
I sort of had an image of a lot
of old guys wearing
tweed and smoking pipes.
The scholars you're going to
work with today do not fit
that description at least not yet.
Maybe in another 40
years or so, but not yet.
So I had a chance yesterday
to hear what they had planned,
and I think you are really
going to enjoy today.
>> Mary Lou Reker: Absolutely.
And one of these scholars gave me
a quote this morning, thanks Max,
that this was published
this morning by Politico.
A lot of you know Politico, right?
The magazine that's been
published here in D.C.
for about what, 10, 12 years now.
Every week Politico cartoonists
throughout the country
and across the political spectrum
apply their ink stained skills
to capture the [inaudible]
, memes, hypocrisies,
and other head slapping events
of the world of politics.
The fruits of these labors and
hundreds of cartoons that entertain
and enrage readers of all political
stripes, and you're going to see how
that happened in the
World War One era.
A hundred years ago this year,
the US entered World War One.
The war had been going
on since 1914,
and you'll learn a whole
lot about it today.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Great.
And one last thing that I want
to make sure you're aware of.
So today you're working
with political cartoons.
They come from newspapers that are
in the collections of the library,
but what you need to know is that
this is just a teeny tiny fraction
of what is here in the
Library of Congress.
Some people describe the
library as the largest collection
of human knowledge and creativity
ever assembled on this planet.
Every time I say that or even think
about it, I get all goose bumpy
and why I do is because I
know that that knowledge
and creativity isn't just in the
materials that the library holds
but it's in the people who are here.
So today, I am really hopeful
that the knowledge and creativity
that you all have really
shines through.
We've got students from at least
nine different schools represented
in the room.
Some of you know each other well.
Some of you don't know
each other at all.
You're going to have a
chance to meet each other
and I really hope you take advantage
of that opportunity to talk
to each other and learn from each
other and really talk to and learn
from these scholars
because they know stuff,
and the way that they're
finding out what they know,
those are the real lessons that
I hope you take away from today
because they're cool scholars
who want answers to questions
and that's exactly what
you young people are.
So thank you for being here.
>> Mary Lou Reker: Oh, one
of the ways they've done
that is by collaborating.
And so, they have set up a whole
forum for you to collaborate
with each other today and that will
unroll over the next hour or so.
I was going to add to what you
said Lee Ann about the type
of collections that are here, and
not only are they huge in number
but the range of what's here.
Everything from the papers of George
Washington and Abraham Lincoln
to Rosa Parks and the NAACP
to posters that are connected
with Cesar Chavez campaign
for justice among farmworkers.
So the ranges of --
>>Lee Ann Potter: And [inaudible],
and maps and audio recordings.
The film. How's that
for [inaudible].
>> Mary Lou Reker:
[Inaudible] movies too.
Yes. And I would love for the five
scholars and the artist scholar
to step forward here because
we're going to introduce you.
[ Applause ]
If you each could say a word or two.
I want to introduce first
Armenoui Kasparian Saraidari.
>> Armenouis Kasparian
Saraidari: Hello guys.
It's great to have you here.
So, we are six scholars coming
from different disciplines each
of which will introduce themselves,
and I'm the what they called
the past few days artist.
I'm a practice-based researcher
where I combine archival research,
theoretical research, and I do art.
So you will be having your
sessions with these people,
and I will be around to help you and
guide you through the art activities
and the practical activities
that you are about to do.
So if at any point you
need specifically my help,
just wave on me and I'll be
there in one or two minutes.
And I'm really thrilled to be here
with you and hope this is a creative
and joyful session for you.
Welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Adam Sheriff: Hi all.
It's a thrill to be here and
thank you for joining us.
My name is Adam Sheriff.
I'm from London, and if you're
joining me, we'll be looking
at the causes of the
first World War.
I normally work on Second World
War but I think I know a couple
of things or enough to guide you
through an hour on
the First World War.
Yes, pleasure to meet you all.
Thank you.
>> Mary Lou Reker: All right.
What number is it?
>> Adam Sheriff: It's table five.
>> Mary Lou Reker: You said five.
Who's got the number
five on their map?
>> Adam Sheriff: Excellent.
>> Mary Lou Reker: Okay.
So folks are going to
go to Adam's table.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Go ahead.
>> Maximillian Buschman:
Hi, I'm Max.
I'm from the University of Munich
and I write my Ph.D. on the history
of hunger strikes within the
United States and beyond,
and I will be at table three
and even my Ph.D. is focusing
on what many people consider
as a non-violent form
of political protest.
I will focus today on
the theme of violence
and how violence was depicted in
political cartoons at the time.
Well, I'm really glad to be here.
Thank you so much for having
me and thank you so much
for coming and joining us today.
It's a pleasure.
Yes. Table three.
>> Charlotte Lerg: Hey
my name is Charlotte.
I'm also from Munich so I'm a German
scholar who teaches American history
so there's already some kind
of weird connection there,
and I'm here as a German
doing American history
in America to American students.
So this is a fantastic setup.
I'm really looking forward to
getting your input as well,
and I'll actually be looking
at the American perspective
on Germany during the
neutrality years.
So if you're in my group, which is
I think two, that's what we're going
to be doing, and we had a
fantastic week preparing this
and I'm looking forward to sharing
this with all of you so welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Charles Laderman: All right.
My name is Charlie.
I'm from London, but I'm
spending this year in Texas.
I haven't quite got the accent yet
but I'll get there by the end of it.
I'll be talking to you
about maps and the way
in which cartoons are
depicted on maps,
and whether that's people
representing countries
or that's animals.
Whether that's bears,
dogs, all manner of things.
We'll be looking at this in map form
and I'm real excited
that you guys are here.
I'm in group one.
You'll be joining me in the
Woodrow Wilson room over there
so that should be very exciting for
you from Woodrow Wilson High School
to be in your namesake's library.
I'm really looking forward
to working with you today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Andrew Karr: Hi everybody.
I'm Andrew Karr.
I'm from the University of Lincoln.
I'm a propaganda scholar.
I did my Ph.D. thesis on World
War Two propaganda comics
so yes you can get a
doctorate looking at comics
which is why I ended
up here at the Library
of Congress several years ago
because they have the largest
collection of comics anywhere
in the world so I pretty
much got to geek
out for six months reading comics.
It was fantastic.
Absolutely wonderful.
And I'm at table four, and I'll
be taking you through the history
of the First World War with a
particular focus on the allies
and the enemies and the
story of how that changed
and how those battles have
shifted and the conflicts they came
into from 1914 all the way
through to the Armistice in 1918.
So I look forward to
working with you all.
It's a pleasure to be here, and
I'm very glad to see all of you.
I look forward to meeting you.
Have a good day.
>> Maximillian Buschmann:
I'm Maximillian Buschmann.
I'm from the University
of Munich in Germany.
I'm a Ph.D. student and in my
Ph.D. thesis I focus on the history
of hunger strikes in the first
half of the 20th century,
and some of my key case
studies focus on hunger strikes
of American suffragettes
and conscientious objectors
during World War One.
>> Armenoui Kasparian Saraidari:
My name is Armenoui Kasparian
Saraidari, and I'm a scholar
at Central Saint Martin [inaudible]
University of Arts London,
and I've been a Kluge fellow
here before working primarily
with photographic archives
and making connections
with the contribution in collective
memory of the Armenian diaspora.
I'm here today for
the week-long event
that the Kluge Center has put
together which [inaudible] cartoons.
>> Andrew Karr: Hi, I'm Andrew
Karr, and I'm from the University
of Lincoln, and I'm
a propaganda scholar.
Well I was a formal Kluge fellow.
I was over here looking
into the comic book archive
for my doctoral thesis
so on propaganda comics
in the Second World War,
and I was invited back
for this wonderful event
by the Kluge Center,
and I'm very happy to be here.
>> Charlotte Lerg: My
name is Charlotte Lerg.
I teach American History at
the University of Munich,
and I have been at the Kluge
for six months last year
and delightful to be back.
So this week has been an
amazing week of teamwork
to create a work-a-thon for
students, for high school students
to work with cartoons from the
first World War and to use those
to help them understand history,
and I'm generally really interested
in finding new ways of
bringing history to kids.
Well, I work with undergraduate
students at home but it's great
to get to know how to
work with different ages.
>> Adam Sheriff: I'm Adam Sheriff.
I'm from London.
I'm based at the University
of Lincoln.
I was a Kluge fellow four years ago
around this time and
thrilled to be back.
I generally work on Second
World War American comics
and historical analysis.
So I focus on methodology.
Well I was very graciously
invited back to participate
in this work-a-thon with
fellow former Kluge scholars
in a new grouping.
So I was familiar with one colleague
but have made four new ones
such as has been thrilling,
and we're working
on World War One editorial
cartoons from newspapers with a view
to running workshops for
local high school children
on different themes of the war.
>> Charles Laderman: So, my
name is Charlie Laderman.
I'm an academic at
King's College London,
and I teach in the war
studies department there
in international history.
But I'm spending this year at
the University of Texas at Austin
and my research focuses on the
first World War on the remaking
of the Middle East the
making of the Ottoman Empire,
and I'm particularly
interested in the origins
of international government.
And I did humanitarians,
human rights,
and the sort of transformation
of the international system
around the First World War.
>> Charlotte Lerg:
I can only predict
that we will have very diverse
outcomes depending on the background
of the students, depending
on the classes that they had
because we are inviting
several schools from the area
of Washington D.C., but the students
are coming from history classes.
Some students come from art classes.
So they will come from
different backgrounds
and then they will have different
focus probably on historical themes
and subjects or some others will
focus more on the aesthetics
of cartoons or the way that they
can react to what they have learned.
I hope for some very creative and
wealthful and unique outcomes.
I can't wait to see it actually.
>> Maximillian Buschmann: At
my table I'm going to focus
on the theme of violence
during World War One
and how was it depicted
in the editorial cartoons
especially from the American side.
So I will show them a couple
of cartoons from the beginning
of the war where violence
and atrocities are depicted
as like an effect of war itself.
So [inaudible] I came up with the
idea that we could help the students
and photoshop cartoons from the
German magazines and [inaudible].
With the photoshop
cartoons and these items,
they can create their own cartoons.
They can create their
own narratives.
We will give them pens
to mark something,
to draw frameworks, to draw lines.
Well, kind of alternate
the story which is depicted
in the photoshop cartoon
and by that they can learn
and get an impression
how cartoonists work.
>> Armenouis Kasparian Saraidari: I
will help out with the activities.
So throughout the week
we have worked closely
to create five different activities
that focus on the [inaudible]
of the cartoon, focus on
the presentational methods
of the cartoons, and we
have designed five different
methodologies that the student
can work either in pairs
or in a bit larger groups
like groups of four people
to recreate cartoons themselves but
also to understand specific meanings
like what Charlotte described,
culture, civilization or barbarism
or massacres in the war
or violence in the war.
So for example, we will be
putting together some collages,
and I will encourage students to
find their own visual language
by using words or symbols or
arrows to express the dynamics
that were going on
during the war and how all
that as a narrative can
come through a cartoon.
So I will be overseeing
how the activities are done
and encourage every student,
even the ones that have
never had art classes,
that this is a wonderful
opportunity to learn, understand,
express themselves, collaborate.
Of course it's also a fun day.
It's a day of school, and I guess
that the students would be really
excited to be in such a unique place
at the Library of Congress
and put their hands
on either the reproductions
of the cartoons or even look
at large scale maps that the
geography map [inaudible] have here
today in our presentation.
>> Andrew Karr: Well, I'm
going to take them through,
the sort of narrative of the
First World War from start
to the Armistice and with the
freedom of allies and enemies.
So who's who's allies?
Who are the enemies?
How does this change across
the duration of the conflict?
What were the reasons for it
becoming a global conflict?
Then you've got this [inaudible]
Italian guy on the left-hand side.
The Russian steamroller and
you've got the Swiss neutral.
Trying to get their
heads a little bit
around the end [inaudible]
trench warfare and then put some
of these difficult subjects from
the source material of the cartoons
to illustrate them and we should
hopefully help engage them
and [inaudible] understanding.
And along with that, we
have an activity from our --
the artists we've been
working with [inaudible]
which I think is fantastic.
I think when you construct their
own first World War cartoon
and from a number of elements
that we've selected working
closely together across the week
so that they can build up their
own record and interpret the events
in their own way and produce this
cartoon at the end of the day
which I'm very excited
to see the results of.
>> Charlotte Lerg: I
want to do two things.
One thing is I want to explain to
them how one particular feature
of cartoons is the connection
between words and images
and how especially by
juxtaposition you can sort
of create a new message.
One of the fears was that the
war would come over in terms
of the immigrants would then kind
of take their conflict into America
and that was another reason
why he stressed to be neutral
in thought but also in deed.
At the content level I'm going to
look at German-American relations
and particularly I want to look
at terms like culture or culture
which turns into almost like a
propaganda term over the years
and changes its meanings
so I want to also discuss
with the students how sometimes
words can change meaning overtime.
>> Adam Sheriff: We're going
to be focusing on the courses
of the First World War and the
outbreak of the First World War.
What I'm hoping to do
with the students is
to give them the different factors
involved whether it's imperial
issues, colonial issues, or
the naval race or trouble
in the Balkans, all these different
aspects that play into one another
and in the short-term factors like
the fascination of Franz Ferdinand
and give the students an opportunity
to create their own cartoons.
This is the exercise Armand
and I have devised together whereby
they'll create their own cartoons
according to how they think
the war would have come about.
And what's great about the
courses of the First World War is
that if you understand all the
factors and you assemble them
in a way that makes sense to
you and you can defend it,
you can't be wrong that there
isn't a right answer to this.
So I'm hoping that the
students will find that engaging
because it's an opportunity for them
to bring their own
subjectivity to the table.
>> Charles Laderman: So what
I'll be doing is teaching them
about the changing map through
cartoons and what we'll be looking
at which I've been
able to come up with
with Armand who's just been doing
fantastic [inaudible] wonderful,
and what we're going to be doing
is a jigsaw puzzle using the pieces
of these cartoon maps to show
them to the students how the map
of Europe changed [inaudible]
in artistic forms
and then the idea will be to
show them the original maps
from the Library of
Congress's board.
These remarkable maps.
,The German dog
and the Austrian-Hungarian
dog attached together,
and they're actually sort of
caught together by their leads.
Because of the treaty they're
forced to fight with each other
and in the writing
underneath it talks
about the Germans having no ally
apart from the Austria-Hungarians.
And these maps, to have the physical
artifact before the mapping will be
wonderful for the students.
So the idea is to show how the
map of Europe changed and also
to show how a mentality
in Europe changed.
These maps, you see them at the
beginning of the war in 1914; 1915.
We don't see these maps
by the end of the war
in some sense this
more innocent time.
This more sort of playful
idea about the map of Europe
that transformed beyond all
[inaudible] description and the map
of Europe is also transformed.
[ Music ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.
[ Silence ]